meantime Republican Congressman Michael
McCall of Texas joins us now to talk
about this Foreign Affairs committee
chairman member of the homeland security
committee uh thank you so much for
talking to me thanks Julie thanks for
having me so uh you know as you know the
house Homeland Security committee will
be holding its first May orcus uh
impeachment hearing on Thursday um
Republican lawmakers are blasting the
DHS secretary for his handling of the
Border first I want your take on this
potential impeachment because clearly he
has dropped the ball
now clearly and if you look at the
founding fathers when they talked about
impeachment they talk about abuse of
power dereliction of Duty uh myus on day
one were sended remain in Mexico that
means instead of arresting detaining and
removing illegal aliens they have
released them into our society uh by
reinstituting Catch and Release um this
has caused injurious harm to the fabric
of America we have 8 million encounters
at the border with no legal status and
we have over 300 on the terror watch
list who have come into the United
States and we have 150,000 people mostly
young people dead now because of
poisonous Fels going into this country
uh that alone I think is worthy of an
impeachment uh and we intend to go
forward with articles of impeachment and
impeach him by the end of this month I
mean it's just a crisis one day after
the next and nothing is being done I
speaking of Crisis here um we're going
to go overseas now the United States
with the support of several allies as
you know finally responding to months
and months of Iran proxy attacks last
night they struck more than 60 Targets
on 16 Iran backed hoodi sites in Yemen
the hoodies say at least five were
killed in the attack the White House
says it was in response to the dozens of
attacks on commercial ships in the Red
Sea including the seizure of an oil
tanker just this week Iranian backed
militants have also targeted US forces
in the Middle East 130 times since just
mid October White House National
Security spokesman John Kirby said this
just a short time ago listen we're not
looking for conflict with Iran we're not
looking to escalate and there's no
reason for it to to escalate beyond what
happened last over the last few days by
the houthis they are the ones that have
been escalating uh we we we don't we're
not looking for conflict with Iran uh
that said we know that Iran supports the
hoties we know that they Supply them
with the missiles and the drones the
same things that they've been using to
attack shipping um and we have made it
very clear Iran should stop that support
yeah this is I mean Iran has also ramped
up its nuclear weapons program in spite
of sanctions uh experts say Iran has
enough uranium to fuel three Atomic
weapons uh Senator Lindsey Graham has
this to say listen when will you realize
that nothing's going to change until you
tell the Ayatollah if you keep hitting
us keep going after Israel we're coming
after you I'm not talking about invading
Iran they're a oil Rich Nation knock out
some of their refineries and a who the
spokesmen had this to say they said that
this will not go unanswered and
unpunished another adding quote America
and Britain will undoubtedly have to
prepare to pay a heavy price and bear
all the dire consequences of this
blatant aggression okay they're calling
this blatant aggression after over 130
attacks this bombardment not only came
after 30 minutes after the US military
said that the hoodies had staged their
27th attack on shipping lanes since
November 19th firing an anti-ship
ballistic missile into the Gulf of Aiden
so the White House on the Pentagon
repeatedly have said that they've warned
of consequences so far there have been
none now they're warning us I mean why
are we behind the eightball on all of
this well that's right it's all about
deterrence about projecting strength not
weakness we've been projecting weakness
uh ever since Hamas invaded Israel
Israel with respect to the iran-backed
um militias Hezbollah and the houthi
rebels in addition to amas um the houthi
rebels with impunity have hit commercial
ships in the Red Sea causing them to go
around Africa increasing prices over
250% so as we talk about inflation back
home think about the price rise that
we're going to see from this Middle East
conflict in addition to the energy
prices as well I do commend the
administration for finally hitting back
I was with the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff last night at his
residence when the call came in from the
White House where he approved uh these
60 air strikes on the houie rebels and I
would say it's about time uh they only
understand one thing in that part of the
world and its force and its power and
they question our resolve in the region
and we need to show them that we're
serious that we're not going to back
down to their threats and we're going to
hit him back with respect to what
Lindsey Graham said we know a riging
ships from the Red Sea conducting these
operations coordinating with the houie
rebels it seems to me even though
Congress has not authorized that and my
committee would authorize that use of
force that they do have self-defense
Article 2 authorities to hit those
Iranian vessels in the Red Sea as well
uh but the longer we let them go with
impunity uh the sooner or later in
Americans going to get killed and then
it will escalate the tensions uh in the
Middle East and prior to this strike uh
the terrorists in the region and they
are terrorists even though for some
ridiculous reason they're not listed as
official terrorists I can't understand
why that is but they had actually warned
of possible retaliation against the US
military targets if the bombing went
ahead uh obviously showing blatant
disregard for the US um and some
military experts are saying that going
after iran-backed proxies isn't simp
simply going to cut it and that the US
needs to go after Iran finally uh what
do you think about that well we don't
want to escalate this but let's be
honest there's very little distinction
between the Hui Rebels and Iran they're
proxies of Iran as is Hezbollah Hamas
and the Iran back militias that have hit
our military bases by the way in Iraq
and Syria and for some unknown reason as
you mentioned I think I know why they
lifted the foreign terrorist designation
on the houie Rebels why because they
want to cut this Iran deal uh on the
nuclear weapons program uh meanwhile our
special Envoy to for Iran is now under
FBI investigation for a violation of his
security clearance possibly leaking
information to the Iranian people or
their officials um I think we're getting
dangerously close uh to a conflict
directly with Iran particularly when you
look at the ships I talked about that
are that are basically operated by Iran
in the Red Sea itself if they cut off
all uh commercial ships in the Red Sea
it could bring Commerce Global Commerce
to a grinding Halt and will cause a
massive uh increase in prices and energy
prices as well I mean we just released
millions of dollars in sanctioned money
we're basically fueling
Iran's Weaponry um it it's just it makes
no sense um that's all the time I would
love to talk to you further but uh
Congressman Michael McCall that's all
the time we have thank you so much have
a great weekend thanks for having me I
appreciate it hey everyone I'm Emily
compano catch me and my co-hosts Harris
vulner and Kaye mcki on outnumbered
every weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or
sets your DVR also don't forget to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
for daily highlights